Musik
Hey, hey, what up, was geht? Hallo, herzlich willkommen! Leute, was geht? Willkommen zu Das Podcast Sufo, das war das ganz fantastische Intro von Malte. Malte. Ich habe gestern Mantti gegessen. Mantti? Ja. So ganz spezielle türkische, ich glaube türkisch, Gebäckform, so Dumplings. Diese, quasi was jedes Land hat. Gyoza. Blini. Blini. Maultaschen. Das halt. Jedes Land hat sich mal gedacht, komm, wir wickeln das ein. Ravioli. Die Erfahrung, die ich auch gemacht habe, dass im Grunde eigentlich jedes Land gleich ist. So, du fährst nach Schottland und denkst, ha ha ha, hier trinken alle total viel Alkohol. Dann fährst du nach Finnland, oh, wir trinken alle viel und dann fährst du nach Russland, nach Deutschland. Leicht anderen Alkohol, ja. Fast jedes Land hat das Klischee, dass sie viel Alkohol trinken. Das stimmt schon auch, ja. Viel Alkohol und dann halt irgendwie in Gebäckform so nudelartig Fleisch einrollen. Weißt du, was ich gesehen habe für diese Teigtaschen? Schön Brühe brühen, schön Gelatine reinballern, dann hast du so eine gelatinige, galärtartige Gelatinemasse aus der Brühe, die wiederum tust du in die Teigtaschen rein.
Also die gallatartige, gelatige,
widerliche, stinkende Masse tust du
in die Teigtaschen rein, weil dann, wenn du
dann die Teigtaschen nochmal in der warmen Brühe aufwärmst,
dann hast du auch in der Teigtasche
saftige Brühe,
weil das schmilzt dann nämlich, die Gelatine,
und damit du es gut verarbeiten kannst,
ist es diese Gelatine, und dann hast du es drin,
und dann holst du die aus der Brühe raus und denkst dir, da beiss ich rein und dann quillt dir so richtig schön die heisse Brühe entgegen, ist perfekt. Aber verbrennt man sich den Gaumen? Der Gaumen ist in Gefahr. Gaumen leidet. Der Gaumen leidet, wirklich. Ich habe das Gefühl, manchmal muss der Gaumen halt auch mit durch, einfach mal, der muss er mal beissen. Der Gaumen muss mal beissen, muss sich durchbeissen einfach. Weißt du, wo genau der Gaumen ist? Ja, ich glaube, der Gaumen ist das, was man mit der Zunge berührt, wenn man die Zunge entspannt und dann leicht nach oben bewegt. Wir reden vom Munddach. Munddach. Und da schmeckt man, oder was? Nee, gar nicht. Aber man sagt ja so Gaumenschmaus, Gaumenfreude. Ich glaube, Gaumen, das ist sowas, das hat gar keinen eigenen Begriff verdient. Es ist nur das Ende von etwas. Ich finde nicht, dass es das Ende von etwas zwangsläufig einen Namen verdient. Es ist einfach das Ende, die Decke des Mundes, das Dach des Mundes. Das kann man auch so bezeichnen. Genau wie jetzt, ich war in Italien, Resto di Moneto. Restgeld ist Resto di Moneto. Das ist das Wechselgeld. Restgeld. Wechselgeld hat auch keinen eigenen Namen verdient. Du kannst etwas selber aus, du hast schon genug Wörter. Ja. Resto de moneto. Restgeld ist resto di moneto. Das ist das Wechselgeld. Restgeld. Wechselgeld hat auch keinen eigenen Namen verdient. Du kannst dir was selber aus... Du hast schon genug Wörter. Ja. Resto di moneto. Rest des Geldes. Moneto heißt Geld? Resto di moneto. Warst du wirklich in Italien oder warst du in irgendeinem Land, wo dir einfach jemand erzählt hat, ja hier spricht man anders. Ob ich in Italien im Bereich vom Phantasialand war, weiß ich nicht, oder ob ich wirklich in Italien war. Auf jeden Fall stand da resto di moneto. Ichration. Clever, das gefällt mir, Gaumen, kann ich nichts mit anfangen, Dach des Mundes. Hundo Millo. Statt Hundo Millo. Lekomillo. Hundo Millo statt 100 Millionen. Und Tausi für tausend. Ich finde, man muss da auch mal, man redet die ganze Zeit über, wo kann man sparen, wo kann man für die Umwelt sparen, wo kann man hier, auch mal bei den Wörtern, wir atmen alle zu viel aus, wir reden zu viel. Ich habe das Gefühl, man kann deutlich viel Text und Zeit einsparen, wenn man sich einmal kurz hinsetzt, mit der Sprache beschäftigt und man sich vielleicht noch hier daran ausdenkt. Was ist mit Sportlern, die viel atmen, atmen die uns nicht den guten Sauerstoff weg? Habe ich mir auch gefragt, haben nicht Menschen eine begrenzte Anzahl an Herzschlägen und wenn du Sportler bist und die ganze Zeit rennst? Ich glaube, das ist ein Gerücht, dass jeder so 20 Herzschläge hat oder 20 Tauben. Ist es auch ein Gerücht, dass man 12 Gramm abnimmt, wenn man stirbt? Ja. Das ist ein Gerücht. Das sind 13 Gramm. Ja. Oder gibt es da nicht einen Film 13 Gramm? Ich dachte, es ist 12 Gramm.
Vor allem, das war ja relativ einfach, da hat irgendjemand, so ein verrichteter Professor, Leute, kurz bevor sie gestorben sind, die so meinten so, oh, noch zehn Sekunden und dann sagt er, gut, jetzt auf die Waage und dann hat er geguckt, in der Sekunde, in der sie sterben, ob sie zwölf Gramm abnehmen. Das heisst, es muss eine Waage gewesen sein, die auf ein Gramm genau war, auf die man die raufgehievt hat in der Sekunde und dann einfach so, ja, da hat jetzt nicht so viel jemand dagegen getreten in dem Moment. Sehr, sehr unstichhaltige Methoden. Ja, auch was für ein entspannter Sterbender, der noch so viel Lebendenergie hat, zu sagen, nee, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, ah, nee, doch nicht, doch nicht, sorry, sorry. 21 Gramm sind es, sind 12, ich habe die Zahlen gemerkt, 21. Aber ist es denn anteilig am Körpergewicht oder ist es einfach ein fixer Betrag, so der Betrag der Seele? Ob es der Wuselig wäre, wenn es immer 21 Gramm wären, die alle verlieren. Aber haben dicke Menschen nicht auch eine dicke Seele? Also ich meine, wenn du jetzt sagst Nachwelt und so, dann musst du ja... Dicke nicht sind eine sehr geschundene Seele, so eine sehr kaputte, von der Welt kaputt gemachte, kleine, mickrige Seele. Kann eine Seele kaputt sein? Ich glaube, die Idee ist, dass die Seele schon überliegt. Und ich habe so eine grosses Ego, so eine riesengeschwollene Seele. Ich habe, glaube ich, eine labende, grosse, fett labende Seele. Aber du musst ja in der Nachwelt genauso weiterleben. Du bist ja immer noch dick dann in der Nachwelt, oder? Das weiß ich immer nicht. Da finde ich, hat die Theologie auch nicht genügend Antworten drauf gegeben. Ey, vor allem, ich glaube, so im Mittelalter, als Leute wahrscheinlich eher daran geglaubt haben, dass man in der Nachwelt wirklich dann noch weiterlebt, so mit Grabgaben und so ein Kram. Wie viele Fragen die gehabt haben müssen, einfach so den ganzen Tag, so Gottesdienst, einfach so nach fünf Minuten vorbei. Ja, da. Ganz so eine Frage. Ich habe jetzt, ich überlege gerade, ich habe diesen schmerzenden Zahn. Letzte Woche war es der Gaumen. Ja, ich überlege, ob ich mir den rausziehen lassen soll, weil, falls ich sterbe, habe ich dann den Zahn wieder oder habe ich ihn nicht oder wenn er schmerzend stirbt, ist er dann wieder heil im Himmel, weil Sie haben ja gesagt, der Himmel ist perfekt. Und was heißt perfekt genau, weil habe ich dann wieder alle Zähne oder werde ich automatisch geheilt für meine Krankheiten? Was ist, wenn ich krank sterbe, bin ich dann auch tot im Himmel, weil also entweder kriegt man alles oder In diesem Sketch habe ich mich gerade erschossen. Ja, was schwierig ist im Mittelalter, weil du musst eine Armbrust erst ganz kompliziert werden. Haha, Spätmittelalter. Ohne einen Zonk. Naja, Spätmittelalter. Ach so, das war mir nicht bewusst, dass wir vom Spätmittelalter reden. Naja, ich finde, wenn du ein Sketch, wenn du ein Improb aufmachst, dann musst du auch klar definieren, in welchem Zeitraum wir uns gerade befinden. Ich war im Leonardo da Vinci Museum in in Florenz. Was hat er angestellt? Was hat er wieder angestellt? Ich kam aus dem Lachen nicht raus. Es war wirklich, das Leonardo da Vinci Museum ist eine Reise Wertmann, Freunde. Es ist fantastisch. Was ein dummer Vollidiot. Also ein Dusselkopf, wenn es je einen gab. Und wir haben damals schon Dumm Vinci hier beschrieben. Richtig. Ja, Dumm Vinci war es wirklich, durch und durch. Er hat Dumm Vinci gelebt. Trottelige Ideen, viele Kanonen, artige Dinge, er hat den ersten Panzer erfunden, auf Basis der, er ist echt wie ein Kind. Also eigentlich ist er wie ich, wenn ich mir ein Lego-Raumschiff gebaut habe. So, weil ich dachte immer, ja, also wenn ich jetzt mit meinem Lego-Raumschiff viele Feinde abknallen muss, oder mit meinem Lego-Piratenschiff, und dann hast du immer so Kanonen gehabt, wo baue ich die hin? Überall. Ringsrum. Ringsrum. Ja. Und die Leonardo da Vinci dachte sich, ich bring's rum, ringsrum. Und dann hat er sich überlegt, der erste Panzer ist eine Art fahrende Schildkröte, so war gar nicht schlecht. Und dann übertreibt er halt immer ein bisschen, weil er hat nämlich nicht nur einen Schuss, eine Kanone aufgesetzt oben, sondern 18 in alle Richtungen. Dann kann er in alle Richtungen schießen. Dann hat er sich ein Boot ausgedacht, was in alle Richtungen schießt. Auch in alle Richtungen, ein kreisrundes Boot. Er hatte eine Pistole, die einfach wie so ein Tablett war, in alle Richtungen gleichzeitig schieben. Exakt, und dieses Boot, das große Problem ist, es ist ein Riesenboot und es hat oben drauf so einen Kreis und in alle Richtungen schießt es. Und ich denke mir so, wer würde da jemals sich trauen, einen Befehl zu geben, weil auch alle die ganze Flotte ringsherum auch sagen, Alter, wenn ihr schießt, Manfred, morgen im Krieg, schiesst bitte einfach nicht. Ja, wenn's geht. Das ist eine dumme,
dumme Idee. Wir gehen alle drauf.
Alle gehen drauf. Wir gewinnen
vielleicht den Krieg, aber wir gehen auch alle
drauf. Das stimmt. Am Ende bleibt nur noch
ein einziger Panzer übrig und alles andere
ist tot. Und dann habe ich die Begründung durchgelesen, warum
er meinte, dass jetzt in alle Richtungen geschossen werden
muss, damit das Schiff nicht vom
Kurs abkommt. Weil sonst
wer jetzt durch einen Rückstoß wäre das natürlich woanders hingegangen. Aber implodiert es dann nicht, wenn alle gleichzeitig schießen und sind nicht so ganz klein plötzlich? Das ist so entschieden an Antimaterie. Aber da muss man dann eben an ins Galileo-Museum gehen. So ein Vollidiot, also wirklich. Dummer Depp. Wie kann man so ein Trottel sein? Ja, dann diese Flugmaschine, die sich so in den Himmel schrauben kann. Ja. Okay, es war ein Genie, aber diese Maschine ist wirklich einfach lächerlich. Ich glaube, dieser ganze Kult hat einfach angefangen, dass er einfach gefeiert wurde für den größten Vollidioten der Welt und irgendwann geht ja die Ironie verloren im Laufe der Geschichte, die Ironie geht verloren und die Leute, der hat einen vierarmigen Menschen gemalt, wow, wow, grossartig, ja, toller Anatom, hat den menschlichen Körper wirklich gut verstanden, ein bisschen ein paar Arme zu viel.
Und irgendwann geht diese Ironie einfach verloren und man denkt sich einfach, wow, unglaublich, was er geschafft hat, der ist auf der Ein-Euro-Münze von Italien drauf.
Was sagt das über Italien?
Ja, was sagt das über die Ein-Euro-Münze? Ernsthaft? Ist das gut oder schlecht? Ich verstehe auch nicht, Abraham Lincoln ist auf dem Einen-Dollar-Schein. Und auf dem Ein-Cent-Schein. Ich habe auch noch... Auf dem Ein-Cent-Schein ist er auch noch oben drauf. Gibt sehr viele Scheine. Sehr kleiner Schein, der Ein-Cent-Schein. Da gibt es ja so eine große Bewegung, die sagt, einen Cent Münzen abschaffen.
Ja, bin ich auch dafür.
Ja?
Ja.
Ich will für Münzen abschaffen.
Generell?
Ja.
Ein Euro Schein wäre gut.
Es sollte ab ein Euro anfangen, ein Euro Schein.
Aber kostet es nicht Amerika wahnsinnig viel Geld, diese Scheine zu haben?
Nee, es kostet Geld, Münzen sind deutlich teurer in der Herstellung.
Stimmt, sowas.
Fuck, vergesst den Gesetzesentwurf nochmal, wir sind falsch rum. Was ich nicht verstehe, ein Euro ist in der Herstellung, glaube ich, teurer als ein Euro. Oder nicht? Das heißt, wenn man jetzt ganz viele Euromünzen sich rauslassen würde, könnte man den Staat bankrott machen. Ja. Finanzieren sich Ein-Euro-Maschinen, Pressmaschinen selber? Das sind diese ganzen Fragen. Das muss wahrscheinlich verwirrend sein, in dieser 1-Euro-Pressfabrik zu
arbeiten, wo man sagt,
wie wir sind Pleite. Ich würde gerne
5 Euro kaufen.
Das macht dann, okay,
Sekunde, ähm,
äh, jetzt muss
ich kurz nochmal zurück.
Äh, keine Ahnung. Was ist daran so schwierig?
Ich will nur 5 Euro bei Ihnen kaufen.
Ja, ja, ja, klar.
Also fünf, Sie haben fünf Ein-Euro-Stücke.
Ja.
Was ist denn gerade der Euro-Kurs?
Eins zu ein, eins zu eins.
Aha, aha, aha, okay.
Fünf, sagen wir mal, gib mal drei, neunzig.
Okay.
Gut, bitteschön.
Danke. Also es müssten ja alle Preise aufgerundet werden oder abgerundet werden. Ja, oder macht man ja aber dann noch fünf Cent. Es kostet halt nicht mehr fünf, neun, neunzig, sondern fünf, fünfeunundneunzig oder sowas. Aber da muss es ja immer noch, also ich finde trotzdem, dass es nur Scheine geben sollte. Der kleinste Schein sollte meinetwegen auch in den Cent-Bereich reingehen. Fünfundzwanzig Cent ist halt auch so ein Ding, ne? In Amerika gibt es ein Quarter. Quarter. Quarter. Quarter. Quarter. Quarter aus Boston. Ist richtiger amerikanischer Dialekt, eigentlich einfach nur Hamburgerisch. Quarter. Quarter. Du, Erwin, ein schöner Quarter. Funktioniert einfach gut. Es funktioniert. Es ist nicht so, dass die Nordfriesen mit den Südengländern fliessend sprechen können, obwohl sie die einen nordfriesisches plattreden und die anderen weirdes Südenglisch. Ach, du meinst die einen haben sich von Englisch so weit entfernt und die anderen haben sich von Deutsch so weit entfernt, dass sie sich wieder annähern in der Mitte? Ich glaube, Hamburgerisch ist so eine Art Graf, der mit steigendem Hamburgerisch ins Englische geht.
Direkt fliessend.
Ich glaube, das habe ich mal
in irgendeiner Quiz-Sendung gehört. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das die
falsche oder richtige Antwort war, rückblickend
vielleicht doof, aber ich glaube,
ich meine, dass die Nordfriesen sich fast fliessend
mit unterhalten können, ohne dass
die eine andere Sprache sprechen. Ich glaube, weil die
Sprache so ähnlich ist da oben.
Skandalös. Man kann es ja auch verstehen, wenn man Deutsch halt so fliessend spricht, kommt ja Englisch bei rum. Muss man an den richtigen Stellen nur Rs und this machen. Ich habe bei Otto Walkes mal gehört, er hat mir erklärt aus frisischer Dialekt und er meinte, Z spricht man wie T aus, also statt C sagt man T, aber damit man es nicht mit dem T verwechselt, nennt man den C Theo, weil die trinken ja gern T und wenn du alle Zs zu T's machst, ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Gag war oder nicht, also der war ja gewieft, der war ja so ein Ulkiger, das war so ein Ulkiger Typ, auch da, er setzt schon bei Otto Walkes ein, dass ich nicht mehr weiss, was ein Gag ist und was Ernst gemeint ist. Guck mal, der ist vor ein paar Jahren erst geboren worden. Und Leonardo da Vinci, da weiss man gar nicht mehr, wie er das gemeint hat. Es kann auch eine riesen Gag-Ausstellung gewesen sein, wissen Sie nicht. Es ist ja der Vinci-Effekt, es gibt ja auch so diese Shows, wo du dann so möglichst bescheuerte Roboter bauen musst, möglichst nutzlose Roboter, die sich immer nur drehen oder die sich selbst kaputt machen oder die irgendwie mehr kosten als sie machen oder irgendwie sowas oder irgend so ein Zeug. Und irgendwann in hundert Jahren schaut man sich das auch und denkt sich an, wie bescheuert seid ihr denn? Das ist irgendwie so eine Spinne mit drei Beinen, die nicht vom Boden kommt. Es geht verloren. Es geht verloren. Ich weiß nicht. Wir bräuchten so einen Humortresor, der Humortresor, der einfach, wo alles reinkommt, was... Eine Humorzeitkapsel. Richtig, wo einfach alles reinkommt, was geckig gemeint ist, wo man dann einfach weiß, für zukünftige Generationen, okay, wir haben hier eine Sprache und kulturübergreifende Sprache entwickelt, damit man einfach weiß, das ist nicht ernst gemeint. Was ist das Passwort vom Ironietresor? 69. 1, 2, 3, 4. Oh, ach, das ist so, es gab lange das Passwort hier in dieser Firma, ach Gott, das darf ich länger nicht erzählen. 1, 2, 4, 3. Ja. Es ist das beste Passwort der Welt. Genial. Man denkt, oh, unsicher. Schickt das mal an Leute, es kommt immer die Mail zurück, das Passwort funktioniert nicht. Weil man überliest es immer. Ja. Eins, zwei, vier, drei. Das heißt, das Passwort ist sogar so gut, dass wenn man es weiss, ist es trotzdem noch sicher, weil man es nicht richtig eintippt. Ja, genau. Ich habe Leuten aufgeschickt, hier, guck euch mal dieses Video an, ist auf privater Link, privater YouTube-Link, Passwort ist eins, zwei, vier, drei. Und von jedem kam die Mail zurück, kannst du mir das Passwort nochmal schicken, das funktioniert bei mir nicht, weil alle 1234 eingegeben haben. Das ist genial. Das ist eigentlich das beste Passwort. Das ist absolut genial. Das will auch niemand raten. Ich glaube, dass diese Algorithmen auch erstmal 1243 überspringen, weil die das für einen lächerlichen Witz halten. Das ist ja genauso, wie wenn du jetzt keine Ahnung sagst, wenn du jetzt sagst, Passwort ist Florentin Will, aber statt zwei L machst du zwei grosse Is. Ja. Was genau so aussieht, was auch keine Chance ist, nur vielleicht eingeweiht oder dies ausprobieren. Das ist ja auch immer so das Ding, deswegen ist immer so Firmen. Hast du da dein Passwortverfahren? Nein, deswegen ist es ja auch immer gefährlich, vielleicht streiten wir hier, nein, das ist ja auch immer gefährlich, wenn man E-Mails von Firmen bekommt, die Ls oder Is im Titel haben. Ganz berühmt natürlich, ich war ja lange World of Warcraft-Spieler. Jufthansa. Genau, Jufthansa. Kann man natürlich auch sagen hier. Hallo, hier ist Margrethe von Jufthansa. Wenn du es schnell genug sagst, ist es legal. Wir sind hier von Jufthansa, sie haben doch unsere Mail bekommen und denkst dir, Luft und dann ist es schwierig, weil du kannst das grosse I nicht vom kleinen L unterscheiden. Und so war es zum Beispiel auch bei Blizzard, mit Doppel-L konnte man immer grosses I, grosses I machen. Und dann hat man Mails bekommen von service-at-blizzard.de, falsch geschrieben, und hat an dem seine Accountdaten gegeben, und dann waren die weg. Das war ein Drama, wo ich mir denke, Leute, macht einfach keine Firmen auf, die ein grosses I oder ein kleines L enthalten. Oder ein kleines O oder ein grosses O. Oder eine Null. Oder eine Null. Lasst einfach die Firmennamen weg. Lasst ihr einfach nicht, denken sie einfach ababababababababab. Und einfach immer weiter. Warum ist man Weggang oder Telefonnummern einfach? Nummern sind doch besser als Buchstaben. Gibt es eine Firma, die eine Zahl einfach als Namen hat, ist es erlaubt? Hätten wir uns statt Statize-Will-Gb-R auch einfach 88-5 nennen können?
Ich weiß nicht, ob die 88
hier drin unbedingt sein muss.
Dann sagen wir 5585.
D-D-A-D, Dada,
Dade. Ich denke an Beispiele.
Es gibt die Bank jetzt, N26,
den Sender N24.
Es gibt RTL2. ProSieben. BDR 2. Ja, ja. BDR 4, BDR 3, BDR 5, jetzt kommt es, BDR 6, BDR 7. Seven der Films. Seven Up, Seven Eleven. Ja, Seven Eleven. Die waren bestimmt kurz davor, sich irgendwann mal Nine Eleven zu nennen. Weil die Besuchergebnisse willst du mitnehmen einfach. Fuck it, die nimmst du mit. 9-11. Und dann kam 9-11 und alle dachten so, Gott sei Dank haben wir uns 7-11 genannt. Ja, stimmt. Das hätte die Firma, glaube ich, ruiniert, wenn es am 7. September passiert wäre, oder? Sorry, am 11. Juli.
Oder die Terroristen hätten dann die Seven-Eleven-Läden angegriffen. Am, wenn die Nine-Eleven hießen? Aber alle. Am Nine-Eleven. Und alle so, was, was ist, warum? Das ist eigentlich der viel bessere Terrorismus, weil das Problem an Terroristen ist ja, dass man eine klare Botschaft senden will. So war das war so die Botschaft von 9-11. Und dann denken alle, ah, okay, klar, wir müssen da hin und Krieg führen. Aber wenn man irgendwie so etwas Wirres, einfach wenn man so einfach hätte dieses Flugzeug genommen und damit auf dem Himmel einfach ganz gross irgendwie Zwieback geschickt. Die haben es auch verpasst, hinten diese Banner aufzuhängen. Ja, das wäre noch die Kirche. Da gab es hundertprozentig einen bei Al-Qaida in der Höhle, der gesagt hat. Der gemalt hat. Ja, ganz kurz. Flugzeuge, super Idee. Toll, wunderbar. Alles Gute. Ja, möchte ich nochmal gutes Feedback geben. Vielleicht mal einen Applaus alle. Dankeschön. Kleines Detail. Wenn wir das jetzt ohnehin schon durchziehen, super viele Ressourcen, wäre es dann nicht einfach noch so die Kirsche obendrauf, wenn wir nicht an die Flugzeuge hinten noch irgendwie so einen Banner dranhängen können, also so diese langen Dinger und dann irgendwie einfach so was sagen wie, ah, jetzt haben wir euch erwischt, ihr Trottel, vielleicht nicht Trottel, vielleicht was haben wir so. Das finde ich ein bisschen aufwissend unter der Gürtel liegen. Ja, ja, ja, ich bin ja nicht der Texter, ne, also Larry, ich will ja da nicht deinen Job ab. Schuhlucke! Mir geht es um die grundsätzliche Idee. Ja. Also kann man nicht einfach da nochmal so eine Fahne hinten dran hängen, wo man einfach noch, hey, die Franzosen waren's, oder so, wir sind die Franzosen, oder irgendwie so ein Scheiß. Und alle so, hä, warum die? Wer ist jetzt genau? Oder einfach die französische Flagge einfach ganz gross hinten ans Flugzeug dran. Wie geil wäre das? Hilf mir nochmal genau, was bringt uns das? Wir wollen doch primär einfach nur die Botschaft senden, dass wir nicht so ganz unglücklich mit den Amerikanern und ihrer Politik Ja, aber... Nicht falsch verstehen, es ist eine tolle Idee. Wir alle haben, ihr alle habt tolle Ideen. Nein, nein, nein. Wir müssen das nicht machen.
Wir haben einfach nur mal in die Tüte gesprochen. Wir müssen nicht machen.
Ich wäre jetzt echt nicht sauer, wenn wir sagen würden, also wie gesagt, ich bin eh, ich bin eh nicht der Typ, der sagt, wir müssen es unbedingt machen, alle sollen nach meiner Pfeife tanzen, sondern einfach nur jetzt mal irgendwie als Brainstorming, einfach mal in den Raum gesprochen, wie wär's denn? Nee, ich bin ja für eine offene Diskussionskultur auch, habe ich ja immer gesagt. Ich habe immer gesagt, bin Laden, liebt offene Gespräche, ganz, auch nochmal vielen Dank an die Seven Eleven Idee. Tolle Idee, aber ich bin mir nicht unsicher bei den Bannern. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob das uns weiter bringt, unsere Botschaft, aber einfach USA, nein, danke oder so, zumindest was Klares oder so, ich weiß nicht genau,, ob das Sider hilft, da jetzt irgendwie gegen die Franzosen reinzuholen.
USA ist mir egal, USA ist schlechter als Kanada, sowas. Ich kriege gerade einen Anruf, ich kriege einen Anruf. Hi, wir wurden erwischt? Ja, wir wurden hochgenommen, weil wir nicht aufgepasst haben. Okay, alles klar. Ach komm, ach komm schon. Wirklich? Schon wieder? Immer das gleiche. Aber es muss doch Gespräche gegeben haben. Hat man nicht auch den Beladen, Ne, es war nicht mit nicht Bindladen, man hat von Kim Jong-un den Laptop, nee? Dein Laptop wurde geklaut, jetzt verwechselst du. Mein Fahrrad wurde geklaut, alles war wirklich an der Geburt. Nee, es wurde von, ich meine, von Bindladen den Laptop gefunden, wie er sichergestellt, und da waren so ganz viele Kinderfilme drauf, Garfield und so. Spinne ich jetzt, oder war Kim Jong-Unterling? Der liebt er. Habe ich aber irgendwann in einer Story in einer Podcast-Folge erzählt. Könnte schon sein. Schaut noch mal nach auf jeden Fall. Geht noch mal in die Faktenrecherche. Wie heißt es, Garfield und Kars zwei. Gut. Stell dir vor, du machst einen Film, der so schlecht ist, dass er Terroristen dazu motiviert, dein Land anzugreifen. Ich weiß nicht, ob KS2 jetzt die Schuld in die Schuld zu schieben ist. Ich würde schon sagen. Ich glaube, man kann die Schuld von KS2 nicht... Die haben... Ich meine, Autos haben Scheinwerfer. Warum sind das nicht die Augen? Warum ist die Windschutzscheibe die Augen? Autos haben schon Augen. Autos haben schon Gesichter. Das ist ja die Idee von den Scheinwerfern. Deswegen sind die ja so. Autos haben die Gesichter und die Rückspiegel sind die Ohren, natürlich. Das ist wie wenn du einen Film über Hunde machst und dann haben die ihre Augen in den Ohren oder so. Ja, wir mussten ja natürlich nachdenken, wie machen wir das irgendwie Charakterdesign, irgendwie die Augen. Ja,, Hunde haben schon Augen, es funktioniert nicht, einfach so, ach scheiße, oder wie wär's denn mit einem Film über Schmetterlinge und die haben die Augen in den Flügeln drin, die haben mal so blibblibblibblibblib, nein, die haben schon Augen, brauchst du sie einfach nicht. Vollidioten, das stimmt schon, die haben es völlig verkackt, die haben es komplett verkackt. Lass mal da in so ein Haus fliegen oder so, Scheiss. Ja, nee, jetzt vielleicht, wir können ja einen Kommentar schreiben oder auf IMDB einen Stern geben. Nee, lass mal Flugzeugklämer und dir einen Scheiss hat Häuser rein. Nein, Quatsch, wir können ja einfach sagen, wir schauen uns dann Teil 3 nicht an oder so. Nein, die Windschutzscheiben Augen, das ist bescheuert. Nee, ich dachte jetzt halt, keine Ahnung,, wir können da ich meine, wir können ja, wir haben jetzt in unserem Filmkritik-Podcast darüber gesprochen, das ist ja dann schauen sich die Leute vielleicht den Film nicht an, dann passt das schon, glaube ich. Du willst schon unbedingt. Bini nimmt das! So ein Scheisskack- Drenksfilm. Unsinn.
Schlechter Film auch. Ja, schlechter Film.
Autos 2.
Warum übersetzt man das nicht? Planes 2.
Ich meine, für englischsprachige
Zuschauer ist es ja albern, dass der Film einfach
Autos heisst, Wägen,
Wagen heisst. Cars 2.
Warum heisst er dann auf Deutsch nicht einfach Autos 2?
Ja, oder Autos
2, da man um eins zu behalten. Oder Autos 2. Ich meine, es ist eh egal. Unsere Serie heisst auch Como Vendere, Drogas online in fretta, auf Italienisch. Stimmt das denn mit diesen Polizisten, die den Drogendealer geschnappt haben? Ja, stimmt alles. Ja, erzähl mal, ich finde die Geschichte grossartig. Da haben wir einfach Leute, es werden immer wieder Drogen im Internet verkauft und da wurden jetzt, es gibt zwei Geschichten, einmal hat ein Mädel über Instagram Drogen Gras verkauft und wurde dann einfach erwischt, weil es sehr offensichtlich war und dann hat noch eine andere, eine Gruppe hat dann auch über Internet Drogen verkauft und wurde erwischt und in beiden Fällen wurde unsere Serie irgendwie ein bisschen in der Pressekonkonferenz Aber hat nicht die Polizei dann so ein Staten rausgegeben, so how to sell drugs fast and get arrested? So ähnlich, ja. Ich glaube, sie haben mit mir in der Pressekonferenz einfach gesagt, so einfach wie bei Netflix ist es dann doch nicht. So eine Anspielung auf unsere Serie. Oh, okay. Ja. Aber um ehrlich zu sein, ist es so einfach wie in der Serie. Und wenn man es so in der Serie machen würde, würde man auch nicht erwischt werden. Ja, aber vielleicht habt ihr mit der Serie da auch sensibilisiert, dass einfach da die Leute mehr aufpassen. Ja. Ich glaube, du hast da schon was Gutes erreicht. Dankeschön. Werbung. Oh, Stefan, du, ich muss dir eins sagen, ey, ich habe komplett den Überblick über sämtliche medizinische Daten und Termine und so vergessen. Hä? Aber du weißt, wann dein nächster Check-up ist beim Arzt oder was? Keine Ahnung. Wann wurde ich gegen was geimpft? Keine Ahnung. Ich habe völlig den Anschluss verloren. Weißt du was? Ich habe vielleicht die Lösung für dich. Wirklich? Ja, die TK-Save-Funktion, der TK-App, die Techniker-Krankenkasse, die fantastische Krankenkasse mit einer tollen App. TK heißt Techniker-Krankenkasse? Ja, und zwar haben die jetzt die TK-Safe-Funktion herausgebracht, wo wirklich alle deine Gesundheitsdaten drin sind. Ist ja schon nützlich zu wissen, weil zum Beispiel wenn man zu viele Antibiotika in kurzer Zeit nimmt, dann kann das ja auch wirklich gefährlich werden. Du kannst ja erst einen Blick haben, wann du deine letzten Antibiotika verschrieben bekommen hast. Echt? Ich hasse das, wenn Ärzte mich was fragen und ich habe keine Ahnung. Wann wurden sie zuletzt Tetonus geimpft? Keine Ahnung. Aber mit der TK-Safe-App ist das gar kein Problem mehr. Dann antwortet die App sozusagen für mich.
Naja, die App hat alles im Griff für dich.
Es ist eine eigene Krankheitsakte, die du einfach in deiner Tasche hast.
TK-Safe ist also die App, die du brauchst, wenn du vergesslich bist,
nicht weisst, wann dein nächster Arzttermin ist
oder du überhaupt nicht mehr weisst, welche Medikamente dir zuletzt verschrieben wurden.
Also, wie viele Tausend Euro kostet dieses TK-Safe?
Nee, ist komplett kostenlos.
Komplett kostenlos?
Naja, wenn du als Mitglied der TK bist.
Alle Infos findet ihr einfach bei einer simplen Onlinesuche nach
TK Safe mit F.
Werbung.
Eine Szene,
über die wir auch mal im Podcast gesprochen haben, bei
13 Regions Y, der Suizid
am Ende. Richtig. Da sind ja die
Suizidzahlen in den USA enorm in die
Höhe gegangen nach dem Veröffentlichen der Serie.
Deswegen hat man sich jetzt entschlossen,
diese Szene am Ende
zu kürzen. Und was ich
total interessant fand, weil das ja zum ersten Mal
eine Geschichte der Menschheit,
ist es ja nie eine Serie, die nicht
existiert hat auf irgendeinem anderen Datenträger oder so,
sondern diese Szene gibt es jetzt
einfach nicht mehr. Die kann man ja auch nicht
mehr nachgucken, weil Netflix kürzt die in sich selbst. Und Netflix ist auch das einzige Medium, auf dem man die gucken kann. Die streamst du halt, diese Serie. Das heißt, diese Szene gibt es jetzt einfach nicht mehr. Aber kann man wirklich mit hundertprozentiger Sicherheit sagen, dass es daran lag? Nee, aber es ist schon, glaube ich, ein relativ gut erforschtes Thema. Also auch im Journalismus gibt es ja klare Anweisungen, wie du als Suizide zu berichten hast. Der Werter-Effekt? Der Werter-Effekt, genau. Und dann gibt es aber auch den Papageno-Effekt. Das ist der gegenteilige Effekt, nämlich dass man auch mit der guten Berichterstattung darüber das verhindern kann. Papageno aus der Oper Zauberflöte, wo die drei Sängerknaben Papageno vor dem Selbstmord bewahren. Es gibt natürlich auch den Pampemusen-Effekt, der besagt, dass einfach manche Effekte auch manchmal einfach nicht in Effekt treten. Deswegen muss man immer ein bisschen differenzieren. Es gibt den Gaumeneffekt, der gar nichts aussagt. Es ist schwierig. Zum Glück lief Star Wars damals nicht, oder kam es da raus, wo man noch materielle Datenträger hat, wo man dann einfach sagen kann, es festhalten, weil Lucas hätte das einfach komplett umgeschnitten und es wäre dann einfach anders gewesen. Ist ja einfach weg gewesen, ja. Es gibt doch bestimmt noch Leute, die dann jetzt runterladen von Netflix oder so und dann die Heiße, das auf dem Schulhof rotiert, dann irgendwie, ja, da ist die verbotene Szene mit drin und so. Oder sich Leute jetzt umbringen, weil die Serie jetzt nicht mehr so gut ist. Kann auch passieren. Das ist natürlich schwierig, so egal was sie machen. Ja. Das ster Ja, fucking. Fuck, Leute, was machen wir? Aber ergibt die Serie dann überhaupt noch Sinn oder wenn man sich denkt, warum taucht die Figur nicht mehr auf? Nee, macht keinen Sinn mehr. Oder haben die da einfach so ein Insert, so eine Texttafel. Hier ist folgendes, so ein lustiger Musiker, so ein Lauftext liest du durch, wo drin steht, hier war eigentlich folgende Szene. Oder sie müssen sich dann anders synchronisieren oder sowas.
Wo ist eigentlich, Werther, sie ist im Urlaub für unbestimmte Zeit.
Okay, schnell, wir müssen dem Auto hinterher.
Und dann einfach ab dann ist die Figur nie wieder gesehen.
Oder einfach so ein Typ, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, nicht umbringen, aber das Bild ist noch da. Über den Credits einfach. Man hätte ja auch einfach ein paar verschiedene andere Lösungen finden können, finde ich. Ja, das ist schwierig. Ich habe nichts schlimmer für mich als so eine Dokumentation über Massenselbstmorde, ganz furchtbar, mit diesem einen furchtbaren Jonestown. Müssen wir eigentlich den Teil auch rausschneiden? Aber wir sind doch ein Comedy-Podcast. Ja. Helfen wir dich Leuten, die kurz vor dem Selbstmord stehen? Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ist das nicht die Aufgabe von Comedy? Die Aufgabe von Unterhaltung? Ja, das ist ein interessantes Thema. Wir haben nämlich auch in der letzten Folge ging es mal um zum Thema sexueller Missbrauch. Und da haben wir hier und da Nachrichten bekommen. Und natürlich, es gibt ja immer dierichten so von wegen, ah, darüber darf man keine Gags machen und so, ich glaube, das ist relativ, ich meine, das durchdenken wir immer mal wieder, aber kommen wir wieder zu dem selben Schluss, dass wir da trotzdem Gags drüber machen wollen und das auch okay ist, aber eine Stimme meinte auch, ob wir nicht Triggerwarnungen Triggerwarnungen geben wollen, sozusagen, dass für Leute die Probleme damit haben, dass sie das dann nicht anhören. Was geil wäre, weil dieser Sound, den es gibt bei Staus, bei Staumeldungen. Einfach vor dem Thema. Dieser Ari-Sound oder sowas. Und eigentlich dachte ich mir so, ja, ich meine, eigentlich warum nicht? Und zwar nicht im Podcast, sondern warum nicht die Puffepäder dafür nutzen? Warum nicht einfach sagen, jeder, der den Podcast anhört und der sich vielleicht mit solchen Sachen auskennt, irgendwie mit solchen für psychische Gesundheit sensiblen Themen, warum nicht einfach da bei einer Puffopedia, bei der Folge dazuschreiben, Triggerwarnung, hey, Sie reden hier über Autounfälle. So, warum nicht? Dann kann jeder, der damit Probleme hat und da einfach ein Trauma verarbeiten muss und da durchgeht, auf der Puffopedia nachlesen und sagen, ah, die Folge höre ich mir nicht an. Apropos, finde ich eine gute Idee, apropos Autor. Wollen wir das noch machen? Also deswegen der Aufruf, falls ihr denkt, ihr habt da, sag ich mal, seid da sensibel dafür und wisst, was welche Szenen, welche besprochenen Sachen vielleicht sowas auslesen könnte, dann schreibt das doch gerne auf die Puffopedia und natürlich der Aufruf, Leute, macht da keinen Scheiss damit, so ist es nicht lustig, da jetzt irgendwie falsche Sachen reinzuschreiben, ist es überhaupt nicht lustig. Mach da für eine Parallelseite auf, lustige Triggerwarnungen, da reden sie über Furbies, diesen ganzen Kram, aber gerne nicht in der Orgie, das ist schon noch dann wichtig, ernst gemeint. Ich bin gespannt, mach das. dass wir sowas vermeiden wollen, sondern einfach nur als Hinweis für alle die, die Bock haben und alle anderen stört es nicht. Von daher, warum nicht? Genau, warum nicht? Eigentlich wäre geil so ein Wort, so ein Command-F, denke ich mir immer, für gesprochenes Wort. Und dann kannst du, wenn du gewisse Wörter, kannst du einfach so eine Blacklist setzen und dann machst du Command-F in einem Podcast und kannst dann Wörter sehen oder Wörter blockieren vorher und dann wird das weggeschnitten, diese Blöcke, in denen sie über Weiß ich nicht, Suizide reden. Ist halt schwer, ob das klar zu definieren ist, wenn du jetzt da irgendwie das Wort falsch aussprichst, wenn du ein Vollidiot bist. KIs können mittlerweile so viel. Ja? Ja. Nehmen KIs oder AIs. Ich glaube, KIs ist nicht richtig. AIs? AIs oder KIs? AIs und KIs, die können so viel. Einer hat sogar angefangen zu forschen. Da hat man, das ist eine, die hat was herausgefunden. Und zwar ging es um so Wärmedämmung und Materialien zur Wärmedämmung. Und dann haben die als Test, haben die alle wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten zu diesem Thema reingeschmissen. Ich stelle euch dir vor wie so ein Fleischwolf. Und oben haben sie die ganzen Arbeiten reingesteckt und unten kam dann ein Ergebnis raus, in welche Richtung man jetzt forschen sollte, was jetzt passieren sollte mit diesen Ergebnissen. Und tatsächlich hat die KI oder AI etwas herausgefunden, was erst vier Jahre später in der Vergangenheit herausgefunden wurde, nämlich hat ein gewisses Material zur Wärmedämmung vorgeschlagen. Und sie hat es nicht gegoogelt. Sie hat es nicht vorher gegoogelt. Und es kam erst... Aber da glaubt, wirklich. Sie hat gesagt, ich habe versprochen, es nicht zu googeln. Ich verspreche, ich habe es nicht gegoogelt, hat die KI gesagt. Ja, und da fand ich es super spannend. Dann haben die ihr alle Arbeiten bis jetzt gegeben und sie hat wieder etwas vorgeschlagen. Und das scheint auch ein tolles Material zu sein, was man jetzt benutzen kann zur Wärmedämmung. Zimt. Ich weiß nicht, Wärmedämmung, nutzt das immer für andere Sachen. Ich weiß nicht, warum habt habt ihr euch jetzt auf Werbedämmung eingeschrieben? Das ist schon cool.
Die Menschheit macht enorme Fortschritte zum Thema Werbedämmung, wohingegen alles andere liegt brach. Wie kriegen wir alle Tauben gefüttert? Wie kriegen wir die Austern zurück ins Meer? Keine Ahnung. reinwerfen. Ich dachte, wir geben der jetzt
unsere wissenschaftliche Arbeit zum Thema
Podcast und so und alle, die wir
eh bekommen, immer von Hörern
und geben der Sakeidas,
damit die uns sagt, was der nächste Schritt in der Podcast- Industrie ist. Ja, oder wir geben denen einfach eine komplette Mischung. So eine mathematische Doktorarbeit, eine Philosophie, eine Ingenieur und alles zusammen mischen und die einfach sagt so jetzt, was ist der nächste Schritt? Was ist der Sinn? Was kommt das als nächstes? Was ist die grosse Antwort auf die grosse Frage? Aber wäre doch fatal, wenn das funktionieren würde, dann könnte man alle Wissenschaftler, müssten dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, kriegen dann so ein grosses weisses Studio, wo sie Sachen erklären. Ich erkenne, wie das funktionieren soll, der bildet halt Wortassoziationen, die Menschen nicht bilden und so. Aber es ist sehr schwierig, selbstlernende Wort-Assoziationssoftware ist das. Fand ich hochgradig interessant, weil wissenschaftliche Arbeiten ja auch, also wenn die alle so schreiben, wie ich die damals geschrieben habe in der Uni, dann kann ich mir nicht zusammenreimen, wie da überhaupt irgendwas entstehen soll, wie jemals etwas erforscht wurde. Man muss auch sagen, dass die Podcast-Forschung, wie ich finde, sehr stark hinterherhinkt. Jede diese, immer wenn es heißt, hey, ich schreibe, könnt ihr, kann ich euch interviewen für Podcast-Facharbeit oder Masterarbeit und so. Inhaltlich ist das immer sehr schwach, finde ich tatsächlich. Vor allem ist es inhaltlich immer die Hälfte der Arbeit besteht darin, zu erklären, was ein Podcast ist. Und ich denke mir immer, wenn wir noch nicht mal so weit sind, dass man einfach sagen kann, ich meine, du machst jetzt auch nicht, keine Ahnung, Ingenieursarbeit über Stahlträger und erklärst dir doch auch nicht erstmal eine Hälfte der ganzen Arbeit, was das überhaupt ist und dann ja, die Gedanken habe ich mir dazu gemacht. Und man kommt da einfach nicht vom Fleck. Ich weiß nicht, ob das daran liegt, dass die Studenten denken, dass man ihren Professoren noch erklären müsste, was ein Podcast ist und dann, woher kommt der Name und wann wann lief der erste? Und ich denke, das ist alles so scheißegal. Und dann geht es irgendwie nicht weiter irgendwie, weil alles immer sich so im Kreis dreht, weil man immer wieder alles erklären muss. Ich finde die eine Frage schon ganz gut, ob man das eher als Theaterstück oder als Diskurs verstehen sollte. Also ob man eher zwei Menschen mehr... Ja, das war dieses linguistische Ding. Das war super. Das war eine super Arbeit, wo man untersucht, ob wir miteinander reden und den Zuschauer ausblenden oder ob wir mit dem Zuschauer reden, also ob wir eine Radiosendung machen für jemanden oder man uns eher beim Reden zuguckt. Also ob man das eher als Theaterstück versteht. Das fand ich sehr interessant. Finde ich total spannend. Auch inwieweit man Rollen spielt als Podcaster, finde ich auch. Ich glaube, was ich eher meine, sind diese ganzen Medienwissenschaften, die sich dann nur mit Medien beschäftigen. Da habe ich noch nie was Sinnvolles gelesen. Nichts gegen euch, nichts gegen die Leute, die da studieren. Aber wir hoffen, dass sie durchfällt. Aber ich meine, ich wollte mich ja selber mal als Nebenfach Medienwissenschaften bewerben und ich habe das nicht mit voller Seriosität die Medienlandschaft umzuwälzen getan, sondern ich dachte mir eher, oh ja geil, da kannst du eine Fernsehsendung gucken. Aber ja, ich wurde nicht genommen, ich war zu schlecht. Für Medienwissenschaften, wirklich. Ja, Medienwissenschaften nicht bekommen, Kommunikationswissenschaften nicht bekommen, im Nebenfach. Das sind aber die, die sie alle bekommen, das sind die, die nehmen alle. Ich nicht, ich nicht. Interessant. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die Nachricht gerade gesehen hast, aber wir haben eine interessante Nachricht bekommen von jemandem, der sich immer noch auf das fucking Buch von Julia bewirbt.
Aber die Nachricht war unglaublich interessant, denn diese Person hatte einen Autounfall und unsere Folge lief dabei. Und dann hat sie geschrieben, es geht ihr mittlerweile wieder gut, aber da war, also da ist alles volles Programm. Totalschaden, hat gequalmt, Airbags ausgelöst, Feuerwehr, Polizei und unsere Folge lief die ganze Zeit noch. Und sie hat auch erzählt, dass sie bis zum Ende, sie wurde aus dem Wagen dann rausgeholt und es lief die ganze Zeit unsere Folge noch. Trotz Totalschaden und Airbags haben wir unsere Gags gemacht. Im qualmenden Auto haben wir noch weitererzählt. Und da, jetzt hinterfrage ich schon, was wir hier immer für einen Quatsch erzählen. Das stimmt schon, aber ich stelle mir vor, sie liegt so auf einer Trage und die beiden Feuerwehrmänner so ... Geh mal eine Sekunde noch, ich will ganz kurz noch mal was sagt der jetzt zur KI? Nochmal eine Sekunde. Ja, ja, gleich, gleich, gleich, gleich, gleich. Okay, gut, voll Idioten, voll Idioten, die haben keine Ahnung von gar nichts. Ja, was reden sie über Feuerwehrautos? Auch so beleidigt sehen wir, wie auch immer die Feuerwehr auch angegangen haben. Stimmt, weil wir die Feuerwehr hassen. Weil wir gesagt haben, es gibt keine kleinen Feuerwehrautos, sondern immer so Showoff-Autos. Was auch nicht stimmt, uns hat jemand ein Bild geschickt von einem Feuerwehrauto Smart. Feuerwehr-Smart. Ich glaube, da ist einfach der Kofferraum voller Wasser und man fährt mit dem Smart ins Feuer rein. Ja, inzwischen kam ich hatte Löschaktionen. Ich glaube, das ist die ganze Idee davon. Aber krass, da denkt man oft nicht dran, dass da ja noch Musik läuft oder ein Podcast läuft. In so Filmen, wenn ein Auto ein Fall ist, ist das oft nicht der Fall. Es läuft oft keine Musik weiter. Oder wenn man gerade eine Schallplatte hört, immer wieder das selbe. Ich denke mir oft, ich höre keinen peinlichen Song, weil ich fahre oft schnell auf Autobahnen auch, teilweise auch echt zu schnell, also man sollte ja eigentlich generell nicht so über mehr als 140 fahren. Ich fahre gerne schnell, muss ich ja auch mal ganz ehrlich sagen. So richtig schnell? Richtig schnell. Und dann hubst du dann auch Leute weg von der linken Spur? Ich hub sie und blinke sie weg von der linken Spur, ja. Muss ich ganz offen zugeben. Ja klar. Und wenn die nicht wegfahren, gucke ich mal, ob rechts was geht. Bin ja auch ganz ehrlich. Naja, jedenfalls denke ich mir immer, hört es keinen peinlichen Song, denn wenn du beim Autounfall stirbst und du wirst irgendwann beim Autounfall sterben, will ich nicht, dass sie mich irgendwie aus Dancing Queen rausziehen, aus einem Dancing Queen Auto rausziehen müssen. Will ich nicht. Ja, vor allem das Problem ist, nicht nur der aktuelle Song muss gut sein, sondern auch alle weiteren. Ich meine, wenn man mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, auf einer Party oder so eine Playlist von sich an macht und weiss, die ersten drei Songs sind stark, die sind richtig gut, also die sind perfekt. Und dann wirklich alle anderen unterhalten sich gerade so und man so schnippt so mit so, boah, Musikschicht. Niemand hat jemand so schnell mitgeschnippt beim Song. Niemals hat jemand... Drum and Bass. Niemand schnippt so schnell. Schnippen hat eine Obergrenze, Schnippen hat ein Limit. Es gibt ein Tempo-Schnipp-Limit. Niemand schnippt so schnell mit. Doch klar. Nein. Ich sag mal, das höchste der Gefühle ist, man schnippt nicht länger. I'll sit and wait. Cause an Angel. Niemand schnippt. Naja, okay, gut, aber auf jeden Fall. Schnipplimits überschritten. Und man weiß genau, fuck, ab Song vier wird es schlecht. Und dann genau, wenn Song vier anfängt, dann irgendwie hast du gerade eine Stille in der Party und alle so. Ah, okay. Ja, ist schlecht. Partys sind auch so sensibel für Musik, finde ich. Das ist immer der Begriff des Rausschmissliedes auch. Und es bringt halt was. Es geht immer. Was ist dein Rausschmeisser? Also wo ich rausgehe sofort, ist sowas wie I'm a Barbie girl in a Barbie world. Ja gut, aber da hast du dann so, dann hast du eigentlich die schlimmste Fraktion, die Trash-Noskal-Giftvollidioten, die dann denken, oh geil, jetzt nochmal ironisch abfeiern, die kriegst du nicht los und die willst du eigentlich loswerden. Die willst du eigentlich loswerden, aber es ist auch nicht der Song, bei dem ich dann abhauen würde, meine eigene Party verlassen würde. Aber vor allem, das ist dann, die coolen Leute bleiben bei solchen Songs draußen stehen. Das heißt, wenn du jemanden kennenlernen willst auf Partys, dann ja bei solchen Songs wie Barbie Girl. Dann gehst du ja draußen und lernst die coolen Leute kennen, die coolen Kids, die sagen, auch von Barbie Girl geflohen, und dann hast du einen coolen. Perfekten Opener. Brillant, Stefan! Ja. Das ist ja richtig gut. Warte auf einen schlechten Song oder wünschst du beim DJ einen schlechten Song?
Wünschst du euch beim DJ einen guten schlechten Song?
Geh dann raus und dann hast du so, ne, auch vor Cotton Eye Joe geflohen? Ja. Und dann hast du schon perfekt laufen. Cotton Eye Joe, das ist das Schlimmste. Und dann fangen die immer so peinlich an, diese Saloon-Tänze aufzuführen. Wo man sagt, habt ihr jemals was anderes als ein Comic gesehen,
weil ich finde diese Lucky Luke-artigen Cartoon-Dances dann auch bei Cutten-Eye-Joe
wenn das mal
Aliens sehen, dann sind wir verloren
ja, das ist schwierig
aber das ist eine sehr gute Idee, erst mal Stephans Flirt-Tipps
was ist denn da los, eine ganz andere
ganz andere Facette deines Charakters
kommt hier mal raus
ja, ich muss ja auch mal ein bisschen tiefer blicken lassen
was so meine Strategie
wie seit Jahren nicht funktionieren. Aber das fand ich interessant. Ich habe mich heute gefragt, anderes Thema, aber ich habe mich heute gefragt, wenn angenommen, du bereist in der Zeit und kommst dann im Jahre 2019 an und du kommst aus dem Jahr 2050 und guckst bei Instagram durch und siehst dann all deine Freunde, die gerade, und du weißt ja, wie sie aussehen, weil du bist älter, ich bin da so weit, du kommst aus der Vergangenheit, du kommst aus der Zukunft, ja, du bist, sagen wir mal, 85 Jahre alt, kommst in Zukunft, in die heutige Zeit und siehst all deine Freunde, die gerade sich selber posten, in der Vergangenheit mit dieser scheiß Altmach-Face-App. Mit dieser Altern-App. Und wie weird das sein muss, dass die alle aussehen wie in deiner Zeit ja gerade schon. Du denkst, da ist das schief gelaufen. Wahrscheinlich, vielleicht ist diese App eine große Kampagne, davon Zeitreisende zu verwirren. Abzuschrecken. Abzuwehren, die einfach denken, oh scheiße, hat nicht geklappt. Hat nicht geklappt. Oder sie sehen alle so ein bisschen anders aus. Ja. Ich hab's probiert, es funktioniert echt toll. Ich hab's probiert mit Robert De Niro zum Beispiel, Al Pacino, funktioniert alles sehr gut, die sehen alle genauso aus, wenn du da alte Bilder reinjagst, junge Bilder von denen, kommen, es ist schon echt schreckend gut, diese KI oder AI. Das ist schon krass, so dieses Altern. Es wird auch in ein paar Jahren ein großes Problem werden. Dieses Deepfake wird einfach ein großes Problem werden. Ist aber auch gut für verlorene Kinder, verschollene Kinder. Da gibt es dann immer den Typ, der dann sagen muss, wie sieht er in Zukunft aus und er sagt dann, keine Ahnung, was sie für eine Frisur hat, woher soll ich das denn wissen, weil vielleicht färbt die sich die Haare, keine Ahnung. Und er muss dann irgendwas machen, irgendwie dann, keine Ahnung, mit irgendwie so einem Ohrring oder so, was auch völlig einfach random ist einfach. Aber da könnte man dann diese Apps gut verwenden und einfach sagen, so sähe ihr Kind aus, wenn es noch da wäre. Was für eine Doku war das nochmal, wo irgendein ganz schlechter Karikaturist war, war das auch bei dem Erkennen? Nein, nee, das war Nathan for You. Nee, ich meine schon eine ernste Serie. Nee, das war Nathan for you. Eine ernste Dokumentation. Das war Nathan for you. Ich weiß aber, dass Nathan for you eine lustige Meinung ist. Da wollte er Kinder als Sportler unter Vertrag nehmen, damit, wenn die erfolgreich sind, er Geld verdient. Ja, stimmt. Aber das meine ich jetzt gar nicht. Ich meine, in irgendeiner Dokumentation, True Crime, ging es darum, wie sah denn der Täter aus? Das war bestimmt Madeleine. Wie der Täter aussah, ist das ja darum, wenn ein Kind verloren wird. Ich weiß nicht, anderes Thema habe ich gerade eingeschlagen wollen. Du meinst die Simpsons. Ich versuche, ja. Ich versuche, seit zehn Minuten das Thema in eine andere Richtung zu lenken. Tu es. Nee, ich dachte gerade an diese Fahndungsbilder, die man erkennt. Gemalten Fahndungsbilder. Und da, meine ich, gab es in einer Tugel im Doku so ein lächerliches Bild. Auf Basis dessen jemand geschnappt wurde. Und es sah so ähnlich aus. Ich glaube, bei Madeline gab es ein sehr lächerliches, es war einfach nur so ein Kreis mit Haaren. Und am Ende sah der dann auch genau so aus. Muss man sagen, ein grosser gruseliger Kreis mit Haaren hat die gewünscht.
Wer hat sich darauf, darauf haben sich ja hundertprozentig Leute gemeldet, die gesagt haben, ich glaube mein Nachbar sieht so aus. Ja, ich glaube primär Leute, die ihren Nachbarn im Knast sehen wollten, einfach die ihr Nachbarn nicht leiden können. Wahrscheinlich, ja. Ich glaube sowieso, dass auf diese Zeugenaufrufe die weirdesten Leute immer, das ist so dieses Klischee, du machst so, die Detektives wollen den Mörder fangen und dann der dumme Commissioner gibt dann gross die Fahndung an die Öffentlichkeit und die Detektives, nein, nein, nein, da verwirren wir den Case und dann weiss der Verbrecher, was wir wissen und so und dann hast du dann die beiden Detektives, die dann so Telefondienst schieben müssen und dann genervt ans Telefon geben und dann hast du immer so die verwirrte alte Frau, die sagt, ich habe den Mörder meinen Träumen gesehen. Und der Detective so, das haben wir jetzt davon, dass wir nach den Regeln spielen, Jackie. Das nächste Mal sollten wir das eher auf unsere eigene Faust machen. So, und dann hast du dann immer diese weirden Anrufer, die sagen, ja, ich habe ihn gesehen, dann ist er weggeflogen. Und dann, ah, okay, ma'am, rufen Sie morgen nochmal an. Ja, das ist dann immer. Da kamen auch sehr viele Anrufe dann, Leute, die irgendwo in Portugal, äh, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in, in Portugal passiert, ne? Ich würde da nicht anrufen. In Brasilien passiert und gesehen haben, so einen Tag später. Ich traue meiner Wahrnehmung so fast gar nicht einfach. Immer wenn ich irgendwas sehe, denke ich mir, wahrscheinlich war es das nicht. Wahrscheinlich war es was anderes. Man sieht ja auch, also ich bin auch kein, ich nehme die Welt auch glaube ich ganz anders wahr als jeder Mensch nimmt die auf so eine ganz eigene Weise, glaube ich, wahr. Sehr selektiv. Ich glaube ja auch immer nicht daran, ich hatte eine ganz lange anstrengende Diskussion mit jemandem über Werbung und wie gruselig es ja ist, dass bei Instagram heute auch wieder, auch ein anderer Mensch, Bomberjacken, er will gerade eine Bomberjacke haben und hat heute zu mir gesagt, oh, deine Bomberjacke gefällt mir und einen Minus später hat er auf dem Handy eine Werbung für eine Bomberjacke angezeigt bekommen und ich glaube da nicht daran, dass man das Mikro mithört. Es tut mir leid, ich glaube da nicht dran. Ich glaube, weil er hat gestern bestimmt nach Bomberjacken geguckt. Entweder das. Ja, entweder das oder halt der Effekt der selitiven Wahrnehmung. Er redet jeden Tag über ein Produkt und dann muss man aus reinem Zufall irgendwann mal am nächsten Tag genau dieses Produkt treffen in der Werbung. Das wäre nicht aufgefallen. Und nur gerade aufgefallen. Oder er redet sogar von von der Bombeer, weil er die Werbung gesehen hat. Ich meine, du siehst ja jeden Tag hundert Werbungen für hundert Produkte und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du über eins davon schon mal geredet hast, ist relativ hoch, aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass es diese Mikrofondinge, aber ich glaube, dass man auch ohne die Mikrofoninformationen Menschen perfekt scannen kann einfach. Du hast ja so viele Daten davon und die sind ja nicht doof, die wissen ja genau, was du dann haben willst. Ich glaube wirklich, dass Google mehr über mich weiss als ich selbst. Ich bin der festen Überzeugung, dass alles, dass Google genau, Google muss einfach mal, das ist ein KI, AI, sollen sie mir einfach alles geben, was ich mal jemals gegoogelt habe und sollen mir mal sagen, was ich jetzt nicht zu googeln werde. Du kannst ja bei Instagram, kannst du ja nachschauen, wie Instagram dich einschätzt, deine Werbeinteressen einschätzt. Das hast du mir erzählt, aber, und da hast du mich da angefixt. Ja, ich habe es dann auf Mobile nicht hinbekommen. Und dann hast du nicht mehr wieder gefunden. Aber auf Desktop würde ich es hinbekommen. Und ich habe mir das auch mal angeschaut, wie Instagram meine Werbevorlieben ausschätzt. Und das ist ganz merkwürdig. Tätowierfarbe war dabei, Erotikromane von der Autorin von Shades of Grey, ich glaube, E.L. James oder E.L. Jones oder irgendwie sowas heißt die. Ganz merkwürdige Sachen. Jesus Christus war tatsächlich bei meinen Interessen dabei. The one and only. Der gute, einfach vor allem Werbeinteressen. Jesus Christus. Ein bisschen mehr Werbung für den Typen, vielleicht irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was er so getragen hat. Kannst du mir das jetzt sagen, das hier findet? Ja, ja, auf dem Desktop schon. Ich will nicht, dass du siehst, was es ist. Ich will nur, dass du es mir zeigst. Ich will nicht, dass du alles über mich weisst. Also, wir führen uns da durch. So, ich bin bei den Konto-Privatsphäre-Einstellungen. Da unten haben wir... So. Flohundin scrollt noch ein bisschen orientierungslos auf der Seite herum. Er verschafft sich gerade noch einen Überblick, aber das sieht alles so sehr souverän aus. Jetzt klickt er sehr gezielt auf Kontodaten, Werbeanzeigen, alle Anzeigen. So, what, what, Interessen für Werbung? Ich bin sehr gespannt, was bei Stefan, Stefan ist ja sehr aktiv auf Instagram. Das ist unglaublich lustig. Unbeschreiblich lustig. Was steht da denn? Du musst es jetzt auch vorlesen. Oh mein Gott, also, okay. So, nun lese ich es vor. Also, es sind eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn. Die Top Ten erstmal. Okay. Auf Platz zehn. Ja. Komödien. Finde ich gut getroffen. Du magst gut getroffen. Du lachst gerne. Ich lach gerne, ich mag Humor. Das ist ein fröhlicher Typ. Auf Platz 9. Hip-Hop-Musik. Und jeder, der mich kennt, weiß, das ist eine der Musikrichtungen, mit denen ich am wenigsten anfangen kann. Ja. Ich höre gerne Querbeet in sämtliche Musikrichtungen. Hip-Hop-Musik ist nicht genau mein Ding. Aber du magst den Lifestyle. Wir haben gelernt, Hip-Hop ist nicht nur Musik. Hip-Hop setzt sich zusammen aus. Sprechgesang, Graffiti, Breakdance und das andere. Auf Platz sieben, acht, essen, zählen, essen, essen, ja essen, du ess gerne, ich ess gerne, aber sieben, Filme, ja, du bist echt ein wahnsinnig interessanter junger Mann, ja, aber es wird noch, es wird du jeder, okay, auf Platz sechs, Sport, okay, vor Filme, ja, auf Platz fünf, Fussball, ja, vor Sport. Stimmt. Nein. Du bist ein riesen Fusi-Fan. Eher, also ich Formel-1-Eishockey, finde ich beides interessanter als Fussball. Naja. Dann auf Platz vier, Videospiele. Ja. Verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz. Die allgemeinsten Sachen, die man haben kann. Auf Platz drei, Natur. Und jetzt wird es sehr konkret. Ja. Ich hätte meinen Top 1. Okay.
Auf Platz 2.
Und ich weiß nicht mehr, wie man das bei Instagram bildlich darstellen will.
Düfte und Parfums.
Ich mag auch die Trennung.
Nicht nur Parfums, sondern auch Düfte. Düfte und Parfums.
Ich.
Es ist wirklich weird für so ein visuelles Medium. Und auf Platz eins, Schönheit. Schönheit. Okay, da kommt noch mehr. Ein schöner, sportlicher, an Filmen interessierter junger Mann, der gut riecht. Ein schöner. Um Schnelldurchlauf kommt danach noch Rockmusik, Popmusik, Innenausstattung, Musikvideos, Fernseher, Musik, Möbel, Hunde, Fotografie, Kochen, Actionfilme, Technologie, First-Person-Shooter-Spiele, Nachspeisen, Software, Rhythm-and-Blues-Musik, Thriller, Science-Fiction-Filme, Rollenspiele, Netflix, Animationsfilme, Bücher, Fernsehen, Motorsport, Computer, Heavy-Metal-Musik, Fantasy-Filme, Katzen, Ausbildung, Student. Aber es ist wahnsinnig unkonkret bei dir, also du bist wirklich fast ein Phantom. Jazzmusik, Bluesmusik, Unterhaltung, Theater, Schule lesen, Spiele, Konsolen, Modedesign, Comic, Foodie, Design, Malen, Klassische Musik, Automobilindustrie, Belletristik, Architektur, Kunst und Musik, Mountainbiking, Triathlon, Grafik, Design, Darstellung, Künstler, Motorsport, Schreiben kommt immer auf Platz 48, Streaming Media, The Walt Disney Company, auch sehr konkret, The Walt Disney Company, Werbung, Zeichen, Naturwissenschaften, Marvel Comics, Kultur.
Wow, nicht schlecht, du bist ein sehr interessanter Mensch, also ich glaube, die Werbeindustrie hat dich durchleuchtet.
Nee, ich glaube gar nicht.
Düfte und Parfums. Ich glaube, die Werbeindustrie ist viel weiter von mir entfernt, als ich dachte. Stimmt, ja, aber guck mal. Du bist ein, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du mit dem, was du bin einfach gerade noch ein gläserner Mensch für die Werbung offensichtlich. Du bist ein opaker Mensch. Du bist ein steinerner Mensch, da gibt es kein gutes Wort dafür. Gläserner bist bist du ja durchsichtig. Sorry, ich dachte, die schauen durch mich. Trüb. Sie sehen mich nicht. Ich bin ein trüber Mensch. Milch-Glas-Mensch. Blurry. Blurry. Es kommt auf die Art von Glas an. Ein Spiegel-Mensch vielleicht. Oh mein, ganz kurz, ich habe Gläsern, der Mensch gerade falsch benutzt, bin ich völlig richtig, aber es passt auch. Sie sehen mich nicht. Die Werbung hat mich noch nicht entdeckt. Ich bin unsichtbar. Nee, nee, nee. Der gläserne Mensch... Also vielleicht liege ich jetzt falsch. Nee, nee, ich bin hohen auch sicher, dass der gläserne Mensch jemand ist, den man komplett durchschaut. Ja. Den man aber trotzdem sehen kann. Glas kann man durchschauen. Ich glaube, das geht mehr um die Worte. Aber was sieht man drin, wenn er aus Glas ist? Aber es ist nicht gut, wenn du ein Gläserer Mensch bist, dann sieht man dich doch gerade nicht. Naja. Es ist verwirrend. Es ist tricky. Na, aber das finde ich gerade sehr interessant. Die Werbung hat mich noch nicht durchschauen. Also wenn ihr da draußen Werbung macht, dann schaut mal bitte. Es stimmt schon, weil wenn man sagt, du bist durchschaubar, meint man damit, du kannst dich nicht verstecken. Aber wenn man durchsichtig ist, kann man sich sehr gut verstecken. Und man ist auch durchschaubar. Ja, du müsstest eigentlich eher sagen, du bist offen. Aber dürfte ein Parfumskrank gut sein, weil ich habe mit jemandem lange über Parfumskrank gesprochen in letzter Zeit. Und da habe ich danach viel recherchiert, weil es ein spannendes Thema war, weil der beruflich damit zu tun hatte und und sehr viele lustige Funfacts dazu erzählt hat, die ich sehr interessant fand, deswegen habe ich da viel nachgeguckt. Vielleicht ist deshalb Performance zwischenzeitlich in die Top 5 gerutscht. Es ist ein toller Beruf, ich finde das total spannend, vor allem, dass man da immer noch Sachen, Innovationen machen kann und immer noch neue Düfte kreieren kann, die ja nicht wirklich nach was riechen, sondern so eine Mischung. Ja, was total spannend ist, ist ja, dass manche Düfte einfach funktionieren und als wahnsinnig, also es gibt manche Düfte sind einfach objektiv super toll, die als Mensch für Menschen einfach ganz, ganz toll wahrgenommen werden. Beispiel ist dieser ganz alte Pakuraban One Million Duft, den eigentlich jeder kennt. Weil damals, als wir Abi gemacht haben, so 2013, 2012 rum, hatten alle Jungs One Million drauf und alle Mädels, ich weiß nicht, ob es Chanel Nummer 5 war, auf jeden Fall geht mal in den Laden und spürt euch links Chanel Nummer 5 drauf und rechts Pakuraban One Million, riecht dran, macht die Augen zu und wer da nicht Abiifeier oder so Fofifeier im Kopf hat, der hat nicht gelebt in der Zeit. Das war wirklich, riecht einfach Teenie-Romanzen, billige Teenie-Romanzen. Ich glaube, das ist ohnehin so das Parfüm der Frau oder dem Mädchen, in dem man das erste Mal verliebt war irgendwie und dem man nahe war, den prägt sich einfach so tief ein. Und bei mir war es ja irgendwann, dass Jahre später mein bester Kumpel dasselbe Parfüm getragen hat.
Wie die Frau. Wie die Frau, was mich in tiefe Verwirrung geführt hat. Weil es wirklich rührt war, wo ich ihn fragen wollte, kannst du das lassen? Echt jetzt? Das habe ich immer im Hinterkopf. Kannst du mehr davon tragen? Und kannst du dich kurz ausziehen vielleicht? Ist natürlich dann die Frage, wovon man gehen will. Ja, das stimmt schon. ist merkwürdig. Interessant, wirklich spannend. Und deswegen habe ich dann derzeit ein bisschen recherchiert, weil ich das wirklich interessant fand. Krass. Auch das Parfüm, toller Film. Tom Tigua. Tom Tigua. Aber die halten auch nicht ewig Parfüms, die kippen irgendwann. Auch da habe ich recherchiert, es gibt verschiedene Stärken. Es gibt ja Eau de Parfum, Eau de Toilette und Aftershave. Und Parfum ist einfach das Stärkste. Es hält auch deutlich länger, da brauchst du auch wesentlich weniger von. Eau de Toilette ist halt die schwachere Form. Aber aufpassen, nicht von eurem Parfum unbedingt das Eau de Parfum nehmen. Es riecht einfach anders, weil die Konstellation einfach entscheidend ist für die Art des Duftes. Also kann es sein, dass euch das Eau de Parfum nicht so gut zusagt wie das Eau de Toilette des selben Parfums. Und wie muss man, also es gibt ja verschiedene Auftragetechniken, du hast jetzt schon die, wie sagt man, die Handachseln? Designer Tom Ford sagt, auf gar keinen Fall darfst du die Luftsprühen durchlaufen. Ah, da wollte ich jetzt gerade nachfragen. Funktioniert nicht, funktioniert nicht, nein. Das ist nicht gut, nein. Schön die Waschstrasse machen? Nicht die Waschstrasse machen, niemals die Waschstrasse machen, nein. Der redet auf die Haut, ist intensiver, vor allem bei deinem billigen Scheiß, den du dann nimmst wahrscheinlich, wie ich auch, will das denn nicht. Ich habe tatsächlich noch ein Fläschchen zu Hause, habe ich schon ewig, ewig nicht mehr verwendet, aber das war? Aber das war, nee, keine Ahnung was das ist. Ich glaube, das ist irgendwie so von Eastback oder irgendwie sowas. Aber das man dann so von manchmal verwendet so für das Date oder irgendwie sowas, aber ich werde dann auch irgendwann so faul und dann scheiß drauf einfach. Man denkt sich halt so, wie sehr soll man sich für das erste Date verändern, weil man macht es sich leichter für das erste Date, aber schwerer danach. Man denkt sich halt so, soll man lieber jedes zweite Date erfolgreich bestehen, aber dafür die Nachwehen schwierig haben? Oder einfach zu sagen, ich hole mir eine 10% Erfolgsquote und dann wird es leichter? Wollen wir uns als Mensch halt nicht einfach mal ein Cut-off-Date überlegen, an dem wir alle entscheiden, so und jetzt wird sich nicht mehr aufgebrezelt für Dates. Jetzt ist man einfach so, wie man ist. Das Problem ist, so hätte es dann... Dann fängt einer wieder an. Genau, das Problem, einer fängt an. Ja, der hat zwei Wochen gute Zeit. Ja, genau. Weil er One Million trägt. Ja, aber der macht einen YouTube-Kanal auf, hey, so kriegt ihr Frauen rum oder Männer rum und dann machen es alle wieder nach. Das ist das Problem, Stefan, wirklich. In der Antike wurde das mal versucht und das ging so dermaßen nach hinten los. Anderer Vorschlag, können wir uns ja mal darauf einigen, wir sind ja geflogen nach New York, hast du übrigens deinen Flug ausgeglichen, CO2-mäßig? Ja. Ja, habe ich auch gemacht, das ist das Wichtigste erstmal. Und dann ist mir wieder negativ aufgefallen, dass man davor zehn Minuten dieser Sicherheitsvorführung lauschen muss, wo man erklärt wird, ernsthaft, wie man die Schnalle von seinem Gurt aufmacht.
Als wenn man die grösste Vollidiot einfach.
Ist das so ein Versicherungsding, dass wenn irgendjemand da verqualmt in dem Gurt? Hier mal meine Frage, mein Vorschlag. Wir gehen, es gibt ein verpflichtendes Datum für alle auf der ganzen Welt. Wir gehen einmal irgendwo hin, meine ich so Schulen oder freiwillige Feuerwehr und gucken uns so eine Sicherheitsverkehrung an. Zehn Minuten und gehen dann nach Hause. Also eine grosse Aula. Ja. Und alle müssen da hin. Wie kriegst du es hin, dass alle wirklich kommen? Und wenn ich sage, nein, ich bin krank. Dann darfst du nicht fliegen. Nie wieder. Dann darfst du nicht mehr fliegen. Das gibt es einmal im Jahr vielleicht. Ja, okay. Wenn du fliegen willst oder nicht konntest oder vergessen hast oder nicht wolltest, kannst du es nachholen. Dann kannst du zu einer Anlaufstation gehen. Ja, also du machst halt irgendwie so ein Keksbuffet oder so, dass die Leute auch eine Motivation haben, da hinzugehen. So viele Kekse, wie man essen kann. Aber nicht mitnehmen, man darf nichts mitnehmen. Ja, okay. Jedenfalls was machen und danach danach gibt es keine Sicherheitsvorführung mehr im Flugzeug. Ja. Einfach heben ab, als wäre es das Normalste der Welt. Und wir alle wissen Bescheid. Das wäre eigentlich ganz gut. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich glaube, das könnte man für viele Dinge machen, auch einfach irgendwie so können. Eine Fahrschule, einfach für alle, einfach nicht irgendwie so einzelne Gruppen, irgendwie der Typ komisch, sondern einfach für alle einfach mal machen.
Ja.
Ein grosses Auto, ein riesiges Auto.
Das man immer behandelt wird, das wird man noch nie geflogen, macht einen irre.
Und es führt auch zu dieser Überlegenheit von Vielfliegern und dieser Arroganz von Vielfliegern, nicht zuzuhören oder schon mal den Neues-Canceling-Profeil rauszulbern. Ja, das finde ich als Leute, die dann so ganz penetrant und offensichtlich nicht zuhören und dann so Augenrollen, so und so. Nee, ich gucke da immer noch mal gerne hin, um mein Wissen aufzufrischen. Bei mir, ich schwank immer, gucke ich aus dem Fenster und gucke, was da krass ist oder gucke ich in der Mitte, wo mir erklärt wird, wie eine Schnalle aufgemacht wird, ist immer so ein bisschen eine Amivalenz. Ja, ich mag aber auch die Animation, weil irgendwann hat man sich anscheinend entschieden, da keine echten Menschen mehr abzuwählen. nur eine Luftansage, das war neu. Sondern die Animationen und wirkliche Animationen von 1989 sehen furchtbar aus. Da sieht jeder so, als wäre er schon abgestürzt. Und dann wirklich, also hast du auch immer so wirklich dann irgendwie das potthässliche Mädchen neben dem potthässlichen Vater und dann kommen die Sauerstoffmasken runter. Potthässlichen Sauerstoffmasken. Und du siehst in den Augen des Vaters so, soll ich mein Kind retten? Also das... Und auch wie Karls Zwei die Augen auf der Nase, man denkt, das kann nicht sein. Überall der Körper bewegt sich, die Augen sind noch so in der Luft, es funktioniert gar nichts einfach. Es sieht furchtbar aus, du siehst, dass das Flugzeug nicht riecht. Das hilft ja aber auch niemandem. Nee, du denkst ja einfach so irgendwie, du suchst da nach so einem schlecht animierten Kind, um dem zu helfen oder sowas. Das ist furchtbar. Ja, muss das schnell animiertes Kind. Du denkst einfach so, nee, das soll auch nicht, das soll einfach nicht gehen. Diese Warnweste sieht gar nicht so aus wie animiert. Null. Das habe ich auch nicht. Aber diese Rutschen, machen das Piloten manchmal? Wir durften ja tatsächlich ins Cockpit nach dem Flug, was super lustig war, weil wir haben das Bild gepostet davon, dass wir im Cockpit waren und dann hat ein Hörer drunter geschrieben, ah geil, ich würde auch gerne mal ins Cockpit und dann hat ein Pilot, ein A380 Pilot, dem geantwortet, ja frag einfach, du kannst nach der Landung rein. Ja, okay. Das heißt, es ist überhaupt nichts Besonderes, ins Cockpit zu dürfen, wo wir dachten, wir haben unsere Verbündete, die Stewardess Podcast-Uferhörerin, liebe Grüße, falls du zuhörst, dachten wir, ah, die führt uns da rein irgendwie, die macht da für uns in die... Wie viele Audienz, Wahnsinn. Nee, jeder kann rein, jeder fragt, der kann heran rein. Aber ehrlich gesagt, finde ich aber auch angemessen, die, es ist nichts wirklich Besonderes. Ich dachte ja, also ich bin großer Flugfan, viel Flugseemel oder geflogen, schon viele Videos angeschaut von A83 Piloten in Cockpits und ich war echt ein bisschen enttäuscht, also weil es dann, es kann nicht den Ansprüchen gerecht werden, wenn man dieses Flugzeug von außen sieht, ist es das größte Passivflugzeug der Welt, es ist riesig, es sieht fantastisch aus. Man fragt sich an der Zeit, wie ist dieses Wunder möglich, schüttelt seinen Gegenüber und dann geht man in dieses S-Bahn-artige ICE-Cockpit. Es ist S-Bahn-Cockpit, U-Bahn-Cockpit, du hast einen Joystick links, da hast du so eine halbgare Tragefläche für deinen Laptop.
Du hast so ein Lenkrad?
Du hast kein Lenkrad. Kein Lenkrad. Aber du hast wahnsinnig viele Knöpfe. Und ich glaube, die Hälfte davon ist Fake. Viele Knöpfe, viele Fake-Knöpfe. Ich glaube, die Hälfte davon ist Fake. Glaube ich auch. Der Falle, falls du umfällst, dass du nicht aus Versehen einen richtigen Knopf drückst. Ja, auch um Leinen abzuschrecken. Ja. Diese, nee, ich weiss schon, wie das geht, Leinen. Und vor allem, ich glaube, das ist psychologisch sogar sinnvoll, weil den Piloten muss ja unendlich langweilig werden. Die machen ja fast den ganzen Tag nichts. Ich glaube, landen ist schwierig, starten ist schwierig, aber dazwischen passiert nicht mehr viel. Und ich glaube, dass die manchmal einfach aus Scheiss auf den Knopf rumdrücken. Einfach aus Spaß, weil es macht Spaß, auf den Knopf zu tun. Und die freuen sich, glaube ich, auch. Und fidget, fidget geht es. Ja, so tsch, tsch, tsch, tsch. Ja, die rumfidgeten. Ich weiß noch, ich habe damals Licht- und Tonassistenz gemacht bei so einem Bauernteater bei mir in der Heimat. Und dann habe ich irgendwie 50 Euro dazu verdient, indem ich da die Lichttechnik gemacht habe. Und das war auch so irgendwie, du hast halt in dem Stück hast du dreimal Licht an, Licht aus, Ding, Ding, Dong. So, und dann zwischendrin habe ich dann auch immer so an den Schaltern mal so, wie weit kann ich den Schalter reindrücken, bevor tatsächlich das Licht ausgeht? Kriege ich noch einen Millimeter? Und teilweise habe ich wirklich auch Einsätze verpasst, einfach weil ich auf diesen Knüpfen rumdrücken wollte. Und deswegen glaube ich, in den Cockpits haben die auch viele Tasten, damit die einfach so mal einfach auch so Piloten spielen können. Einfachfach so, oh, da ist jetzt eine Gans ins Triebwerk geflogen, Ersatzmotoren, zack, zack, oh, er ist hier hin, Mayday, Mayday, Mayday, Achtung, Triebwerkfeuer, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, klick, nicht echtes Mayday, sorry, sorry, nein, nein, sorry, sorry, mann Spaß, mann Spaß, ja, genau, ja, sorry, wir haben, tschau, tschau, tschau, tschau. Geil wäre eigentlich, wenn die das so ausschalten könnten, das Cockpit, und in das stimmt. Und in so einem Play-Mode. Und dann funktionieren keine Klopfe mehr. Die haben so einen Reusper-Knopf bestimmt, oder? Weiß ich nicht. Dass die das kurz mal rausmuten können für eine kurze Zeit. Ein Fun-Knopf. Aber ich habe gehört, dass die Flugsicherung da mithört und du keine Person während dem Flug ins Cockpit lassen darfst. Ja, vor allem ist es ja auch, meinte sie, auf USA flügen besonders schwierig. Genau. Weil die hatten da schon mal Probleme. Und wenn die, wirklich? 7-Eleven. Und wenn die da fremde Stimmen hören, dann wird die sofort abgeschossen. Also die Flugzeugung hört da mit und wenn da fremde Stimmen im Cockpit sind, wenn die sofort abschissen. Ich kann halt sehr gut Robert Pattinson imitieren. Ich meine, du bist ganz doll krank. Und dann hustest du bis zum Schwein. Hanno, weide. Ja, direkt weg. Ja, wenn du eine tolle Donald Duck-Impression oben zeigst. Deswegen ja auch tatsächlich die erste Frage bei jeder Pilotenausbildung. Können sie gut Stimmen imitieren? Ja, Applaus, Applaus. Und raus. Fort raus. Sie werden abgeschossen. Sehr lustig, aber weg hier. Sehr lustig, aber lachend werden sie hinauskomplimentiert. Ja, ich muss mich todlachen, aber hauen sie hier alles Robert De Niro. Fantastisch, als stünde er vor mir oder hinter mir. Aber raus! Sowas von raus! Nee, aber waren auf jeden Fall, vielen Dank an die Piloten, auch ganz fantastisch, hat viel grossen Spaß. Sehr nett, sehr, sehr nett. Riesenteil. Ich habe mir vorher die ganze Zeit überlegt, was stelle ich für eine Frage. Und dann habe ich mich durchgerungen zu Wie fliegt er sich? Ja, und das mag ich an Stefan, dass er in der Situation so ein kumpelhaftes, jetzt mal im Ernst, wie fliegt er sich? Ja, rückblickend habe ich nicht genau mehr verstanden, was ich mir von erwartet habe, weil ich bin noch nie geflogen. Erstmal klang es falsch, es klang so, als ob ich flieg gerne und viel fliege und mindestens schon mal in Aero 20 sicher gelandet bin. Und was nicht mitschwingt ist, ich bin noch nie geflogen und was ich auch nicht bedacht habe, war, dass jegliche Antwort nicht hilft. Richtig. Wie fliegt er sich? Aber er hat auch dann erst gelacht, weil er nicht wusste, wie er darauf antworten soll, sondern hat dann gesagt, ja, man muss ihn halt so ein bisschen kommen lassen. Und dann habe ich cool genickt, aber auch nicht verstanden, was er meinte. Ja, er muss manchmal ein bisschen gegenlenken, ne? Okay. Klingt vor allem gefährlich, wie sie müssen gegenlenken. Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber das war wirklich so kommen lassen. Wir wussten schon eine halbe Stunde ungefähr davor, vor der Landung, dass wir ins Cockpit dürfen. Und ich habe Stefan gesagt, bitte überlegt ihr sinnvolle Fragen. Und ich dachte, was kommt da jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, wie sieht das eigentlich aus im Klimawandel irgendwie, muss man als Pilot sich dann nicht nach einem neuen Job umsehen, wenn es keine Flugzeuge mehr gibt und so. Das ist eine coole Frage. Und hin und wer und du so, oh wie fliegt er sich? Einfach mit so einem kumpelhaften Ellbogenstoß. Mit einer Pilotenbrille auf undotenbrille auf und mit so einem Pilotenkostüm an, habe ich gefreut, mit so einem wunderschönen Preisschild dranhängt. Wie fliegt er sich, seine Kollegen? Wie fliegt er sich, die alte Möhre hier? Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, ich wollte nicht, ich dachte, ich kann dagegen klopfen. Sorry, sorry. Gehen Sie meinen Donut-Duck-Impression? Nein! Ja. Rückblickend bin ich stolz auf uns, was nicht schiefgegangen ist. Ja, und ich habe auch während dem Flug, gibt es ja so ein Entertainment-System im Flugzeug. Und das Beste natürlich daran, die Außenkameras. Die Außenkameras, es gibt eine Kamera nach unten. Es gibt mittlerweile drei Stück. Sehr schlechte Braille-Tail. Ich habe die ganze Zeit Live-Rigie gespielt, die ganze Zeit habe ich, und jetzt Achtung für die Eins, Eins. Ja, und auf die Zwei, in drei, zwei, eins und zwei. Und drei, drei, drei, drei, drei, in Position. Und rechts von mir, links von mir der Typ, hat nicht auf seinem Bildschirm gestaut die ganze Zeit. Er hat auf seinem Laptop eine Serie geguckt. War sehr fasziniert von meiner Außenkamera, auf meinem Bildschirm. Und da habe ich gesehen, dass ich ihn auch gerade unterhalte. Und habe für ihn Live-Rigie gespielt. Und in meinen richtigen Momenten waren die Landeklappen, ich sehe ja draußen, die Landeklappen werden ausgefahren, direkt und Achtung fürchtung für die drei. Ah, geil, geil. Das Tolle war, es gab eine Kamera, die direkt vorne war, also an der Spitze des Flugzeugs, Nase, glaube ich, sagt man auch, oder? Bug. Und nachdem das Flugzeug gelandet ist, wird es ja so eingewiesen von so Flughafenmitarbeitern. Ja! Und es gab einen Moment, wo dieser Arbeiter direkt vor der Kamera stand und der einfach wirklich bildschirmfüllend
irgendwie direkt, wo ich mir dachte, weiss der,
dass der gefilmt wird gerade? Aber wie geil der war.
Der war super. Erstmal, der winkt,
der winkt, winkt, winkt, wild rum,
auch völlig unkolliniert, auch je nachdem, wo du landest,
völlig egal, winkt, wild rum,
und dann kommt der Flieger und dann kommen diese,
ja, diese
beiden Arme, die oben zusammengehen.
Ach so, ja, ja. Die beiden Arme, die oben zusammengehen, immer näher zusammen, immer näher zusammen, immer näher zusammen, und dann kommt der Meier das Kreuz. Dann kommt das Kreuz. Komm, lass, komm, lass. Dann ist es vorbei. Und der Pilot bei uns hat die ganze Zeit eher angehalten, war so fast am Ziel. Und natürlich hat die ganze Zeit Arme hochgehalten und hat gesagt, komm noch ein bisschen, komm noch ein bisschen. Aber dem Pilot war es scheißegal, hat das Feierababend gemacht, Paket, Anschnallzeichen war schon lange aus. Deswegen mussten wir beim Aussteigen auch so einen Meter Sprung machen, um in diese Röhre zu kommen. Nee, ist aber kein Problem, es war einfach so ein Millimeter, der gefehlt hat, aber der Typ war einfach ein bisschen sauer. Dann hat er irgendwann gesagt, ja komm, dann lass. Hat er dann auch so abgewunken und er war einfach live drauf bei mir. Ich stelle mir vor allem vor, du machst ja eine jahrzehntelange Ausbildung zum Flughafeneinweiser und am letzten Tag kriegst du dann diese Leuchthörnchen.
Und dann wirklich so ein großer Koffer wird dann so geöffnet und da sind dann diese orangen Leuchthörnchen und man so, bin ich würdig und hundertprozentig, jeder einzelne Flughafenmitarbeiter hat schon mal das Lichtschwert gemacht.
Hat diese Dinge und dann, weil dich hört ja niemand, ist ja alles wahnsinnig laut.
Die meisten haben das von den nachts zu Hause gemacht, am meisten Tag haben sie bekommen. Darf man die mit nach Hause nehmen? Und dann einfach so kommt die Schwiegermutter zu Besuch und man weist sie so ein und zurück, zurück, zurück. Stopp, stopp, weiter, weiter. Hör auf jetzt, Gerhard. Ja. Aber das stelle ich mir sehr. Das ist eigentlich so ein Job, den ich auch gerne machen würde. Flughafen, nein. Du hast Kopfhörer auf, du kannst ja einfach einen Podcast anschmeissen, drunter und den Kopfhörern, kein Problem, und dann fährst du mit diesen kleinen Wägen durch die Gegend. Die Sausen, die Flitzenden, Flughafenfahrzeuge sind wirklich eine ganz andere Welt. Ich glaube, es wäre ein guter Job für dich, überarbeitest dich nicht. Weißt du, was auch eine andere Welt für uns ist? Die Jugend. Wir haben mittlerweile komplett den Anschluss verloren an die Jugend. Wir sind ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr die Jüngsten, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, aber gefühlt ist man immer noch jung im Kopf. Ich bin auch sehr jung im Kopf, wir können aber trotzdem nicht mehr mithalten, vor allem für euch da draußen, die selber jung seid oder Leute, die wieder jung sein wollt. Wir haben aber einen Strohhalm, an dem wir uns ganz doll greifen. Unsere Nabelschnur in die heutige Jugend, nämlich unsere ehemalige... Unser Dosentelefon. Unsere Faxmaschine in die Jugend.
Unser Dosen-iPhone nach draußen,
nämlich unsere ganz tolle Mitarbeiterin, die Thais.
Ja, die hat nämlich einen kleinen Beitrag gemacht, um uns so ein bisschen aufzuklären.
Was findet gerade in der Jugend statt, was ist gerade hip, was ist...
Worin frönt die Jugend?
Richtig, ja, was muss man eigentlich tun, um so richtig dabei zu sein, um so richtig hip zu sein?
Und sie wird es uns sagen, und wir hören mal rein, ganz viel Spaß jetzt mit Thais. Oder für G-Spinner raus. Hey Leute, Florentin und Stefan haben mich vor einiger Zeit gebeten, ihnen ein paar Tipps zu geben, wie sie zurück zur Jugend finden. Ihr fragt dich wahrscheinlich, wieso das so lange gedauert hat. Nun ja, nachdem ich vor einigen Monaten ein paar Stunden mit Stefan und Florentin verbracht habe, war ich selbst so unjugendlich wie noch nie. Deshalb musste ich in ein paar
Wochen abtauchen, in meiner Generation, um wieder zu spüren, was Jugend ist. Hier bin
ich jetzt mit ein paar freshen Tipps und tools am Start. Der erste Tipp ist, wie es
sich natürlich für Jugendliche gehört, Party, Party, Party. Ob man jetzt eingeladen wurde
oder nicht, ist da gar nicht so wichtig. Auf der Party dann einfach in der Ecke hocken und bisschen Shisha dampfen. Super cool kommt's, wenn man an der Shisha dann ein paar Tricks vorführen kann. Also aus dem Dampf Ringe formt, Quadrate, Dreiecke, irgendwie sowas. Stefan, dieser Tipp ist speziell für dich. Wenn du mal wieder auf deinem Bustelbott rumcruist, musst du ganz hart mit fetten Boxen 500 PS von Bones MC und Rav Camorra spielen.
Bei jeder Kurve musst du dann auch sowas wie Skü-Skü rufen. Ihr anderen könnt alternativ dazu auch die Fans dann auch im Auto runterlassen, die Musik geniessen und die Geräusche von euch geben, aber machen wir uns nichts vor. Auf dem Bustelboard ist es natürlich viel mehr Premium als im Auto, ne? Social Media. Auch wenn es hart ist und man lieber an Thomas Mann lesen würde, einfach mal drei bis vier Stunden irgendwas Hirnverbranntes auf YouTube gucken und Insta abchecken. Das ist harte Arbeit, aber nötig, um hip zu bleiben. Der nächste Tipp ist eigentlich auch ganz simpel. Ihr müsst einfach überall diese Pipa-Sonnenblumenkerne essen und die Schalen hinspucken. Ob auf dem Schulhof oder beim Bewerbungsgespräch ist ganz egal. Übrigens, Tipp am Rande, wenn man mal nicht eingeladen wurde, einfach den Sonnenblumenhülsenspuren aus der Strasse folgen, um zu den Hotspots der Jugend zu kommen. So, das war's jetzt für heute. Ich hoffe, wenn wir uns das nächste Mal sehen, seid ihr Shisha-Rauch und in irgendeiner Ecke auf einem Thron aus Pipa-Kern. Peace out, kann sie beantworten? Das kann sie in der Tat. Wir werden die nächsten Fragen erst für nächste Woche beantworten, wenn es wieder heißt. Hallo zum Podcast-Hofo. Hier ist, wie heißt es nochmal? Das Podcast, den wir machen. Wir wünschen eine entspannte Woche. Kommt gut durch die Woche, kommt gut durch die Wärme, die jetzt wiederkommt. Ich weiß es auch auch nicht, wird es kalt, keine Ahnung, wenn Leute sagen, es sollte doch warm werden, vor allem woher wusste das, guckt die Eier noch, niemand guckt doch in diese Eier, ist doch egal.
Kommt gut an, Leute, haut rein, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche.